.
Le dernier pavillon construit
sur le site de l'ancien hôpital
St-Luc, qui a été démoli en
avril 2018, est prêt à
accueillir ses premiers
patients. Mais après des années
de débats, de reports
et aussi de controverses sur
l'emplacement du futur méga
hôpital, entre autre sur
le terrain de la gare de triage
d'Outremont, eh bien, le projet
est finalement lancé.
C'est le premier  ministre
Jean Charest, accompagné
des ministres Yves Bolduc et
Monique Gagnon-Tremblay, qui a
donné donne la première pelletée
de terre au projet,
le 25 mars 2010.
Une construction évaluée,
à cette époque, à près
d'un demi milliard de dollars.
Le méga hôpital est enfin
terminé et aura coûté finalement
3 milliards 600 millions
de dollars, sept fois plus.
- On rentre dans le nouveau
maintenant.
- Voici à quoi ressemble
le nouveau pavillon qui
accueille un centre ambulatoire
et aussi le centre
de cancérologie intégré.
Dr FABRICE BRUNET, président-
directeur général, CHUM
- On a intégré tous les besoins
des patients avec cancer
sur place, y compris
s'il y a des urgences.
- Ce qui frappe le plus en
circulant dans les nouveaux
locaux, et bien c'est l'espace,
la lumière et surtout des vues
magnifiques sur la ville.
De l'espace surtout pour
les futurs patients.
DANIELLE FLEURY,
PDG adjoint, CHUM
- Ici, ce qu'on a en plus,
parce qu'on est dans un centre
ambulatoire, on a aussi
12 civières où les patients
pourront avoir comme
une hospitalisation de jour ou
des traitements qui demandent
une plus longue période.
- Le Centre hospitalier
de l'Université de Montréal est
le plus grand au Québec et parmi
l'un des plus importants
au Canada.
- Ici, c'est toute une équipe
qui s'occupe de vous, ce qu'on
appelle une famille, et en fait,
le patient se sent comme au sein
d'une famille et non pas
dans un hopital froid.
- Le nouveau pavillon accueille